VIOLENCE WILL BE AN UPHILL
BATTLE AS POLICE DEPARTMENTS ARE
FACING CRITICAL STAFFING
SHORTAGES.
>> MORE SHOOTINGS AND MORE 911
CALLS HAVE POLICE DEPARTMENTS
AROUND THE COUNTRY STRUGGLING TO
MEET THE GROWING NEED WITH
DEPARTMENTS STRETCHED THIN.
HEADING INTO A BUSY SUMMER WHERE
CALLS FOR 911 EMERGENCY SERVICE
SPIKED.
>> IS SHE THREATENING OR
FIGHTING WITH ANYBODY RIGHT NOW?
>> IS NOT ONLY ARE YOU GETTING
THE SHORTAGES OUT IN THE FIELD,
BUT IN THIS ROOM.
>> THE PEOPLE WHO WORK HERE ARE
WORKING LONG HOURS.
EXTRA OVERTIME TO COVER OTHER
SHIFTS, BUT WE HAVE TO HAVE
SOMETHING ANSWERING THE CALL.
IT'S CRITICAL.
>> THE WORKER SHORTAGE IS
DISRUPTING PUBLIC SAFETY AROUND
THE COUNTRY BY CAUSING DELAYS IN
LAW ENFORCEMENT RESPONSE TIMES
AND A REDUCTION IN DETECTIVES
WORKING CASES.
>> WHERE HAS THE AMERICAN
WORKFORCE GONE?
LIKE THEY JUST BANISHED.
POLICE, WE'RE NOT IMMUNE TO IT.
>> IN KANSAS CITY, MISSOURI, THE
MAYOR IS SEEING A SHORTAGE
ACROSS ALL OPEN JOBS AND TELLS
US HIRING MORE RECRUITS IN THIS
TOUGH MARKET IS A PRIORITY.
>> WE WILL NOT HAVE ENOUGH
OFFICERS TOMORROW, BUT MORE THAN
ANYTHING, WE NEED TO TRY TO MAKE
SURE WE'RE HELPING TO MAKE SURE
OTHERS KNOW POLICING IS A GOOD
PATH.
>> LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICES ARE
NOW OFFERING HIRING BONUSES AS
HIGH AS $20,000 AND SOME
DEPARTMENTS HAVE STARTED PAYING
BONUSES TO KEEP CURRENT
OFFICERS.
IN PORTLAND, OREGON, THEY ARE
SHORT 108 OFFICERS.
IN DALLAS, THEY ARE SHORT 550
NAND KANSAS CITY, MISSOURI, THEY
ARE SHORT SOME 225 HOURS WHILE
IN ATLANTA, THE MAYOR SAYS HE
HAS IMMEDIATE OPENINGS.
>> PEOPLE ARE ANSWERING THE
CALL.
>> ONE OF THE CHALLENGES, EVERY
POLICE DEPARTMENT IS LOOKING FOR
THE SAME GROUP OF TALENTED,
MOTIVATED INDIVIDUALS THAT HAVE
A HEART TO SERVE.
>> RIGHT NOW, WE'RE LOOKING AT
MILITARY BASES, BUT ALSO HBCUs.
CAN'T JUST TALKING ABOUT GETTING
MORE OFFICERS OF COLOR.
GO TO THE CAMPUSES, TALK TO THEM
ABOUT POLICING, THE WORK WE DO.
>> WE LIKE TO WAIT AROUND FOR
THE PEOPLE AT THE TOP TO CHANGE
THE CULTURE.
>> A LAW ENFORCEMENT TRAINING
GROUP IS HELPING EACH POLICE
DEPARTMENTS TO REACH MORE
APPLICANTS.
>> I CAN LEGITIMATELY GO OUT
THERE AND BE THE CHANGE THAT THE
COMMUNITY WANTS TO SEE WITHOUT
ANYBODY HAVING TO IMPRESS UPON
ME WHAT I NEED TO DO.
>> THAT RIPPLE EFFECT OF NOT, OF
THE WORKLOAD AND STRESS IS BEING
PLACED ON POLICE OFFICERS HAS
INCREASED TO OUR CURRENT
STAFFING AS WELL AS WHAT IS
APPLYING.
SO WE'RE KIND OF IN THE PERFECT
STORM RIGHT NOW.
>> JAKE, THAT STRESS IS REAL.
ON A SAD NOTE, WE KNOW OF THREE
OFFICERS WHO DIED BY SUICIDE
THIS MONTH ALONE IN THE CITY OF
CHICAGO.
AND ACROSS THE COUNTRY, A LOT